Olá tudo bem Aqui o Dr Alan Machado
Dutra médico há mais de 25 anos e hoje
eu vou falar sobre sinais e sintomas do
intestino hiper permeável bem você já
deve ter ouvido né todas as doenças
começam intestino disse Hipócrates o pai
da Medicina moderna e Olha só pessoal
mais de dois milênios depois estamos
aqui com um monte de Pesquisas na mão
provando que ele sabia das coisas Desde
aquela época isso me faz pensar todos os
dias no consultório vendo caso após caso
de pacientes como essa ideia tão atual e
importante tão relevante hoje em dia o
intestino hiper permeável conhecido lá
fora como liqu Gut Pode parecer só mais
um termo médico mas é fundamental
entendermos que essa condição está na
raiz de uma série de doenças modernas
desde diabetes fibromialgia Fadiga
Crônica até depressão passando por
obesidade doenças cardíacas câncer a
doenças autoimunes e até autismo É sério
por isso esse vídeo é um dos mais
importantes que eu já fiz aqui no canal
pessoal na medicina funcional damos uma
atenção toda especial ao intestino
Especialmente quando falamos de
intestino hiper permeável na minha
prática médica diária uma das primeiras
coisas que eu faço avaliar um paciente é
checar Como está sua saúde intestinal e
não é por acaso Se o intestino não está
funcionando como deveria todo o resto
que t tentamos fazer para melhorar a
saúde da pessoa pode não ter o efeito
esperado sabe por quê cerca de 70 a 80%
do seu sistema de defesa imune está
localizado no intestino aproximadamente
90% da serotonina aquele
neurotransmissor responsável pela
sensação de bem-estar também é produzido
ali no intestino isso faz com que esse
órgão seja conhecido como segundo
cérebro agora pense nisso se o sistema
imune que vive em grande parte no
intestino não estiver saudável aí
começam os problemas isso pode
comprometer a nossa capacidade de defesa
contra invasores externos então manter o
intestino saudável é mais do que um
objetivo é uma necessidade fundamental
Se quisermos garantir uma boa saúde
geral para compreender o que é o
intestino hiper permeável precisamos
primeiro olhar para a estrutura dos
nossos intestinos eles são protegidos
por uma camada única de células
epiteliais que são como guardiãs
especializadas Unidas entre si por
proteínas de junção essas proteínas
funcionam como uma porta entre o nosso
intestino e a corrente sanguínea
estabelecendo uma barreira que é
essencial o trabalho dessas proteínas é
manter o equilíbrio delicado elas devem
permitir que nutrientes vitais sejam
absorvidos pela nossa corrente sanguínea
e ao mesmo tempo impedem a passagem de
substâncias nocivas como é o caso de
toxinas bactérias ou constituintes
bactérias e macromoléculas não
digeríveis isso é fundamental pra nossa
saúde Então vamos usar uma analogia uma
comparação para simplificar imagine o
nosso intestino como filtro de café
projetado para permitir que apenas o
líquido do café passe enquanto mantm o
pó ou grãos de café retido se de repente
esse filtro desenvolve pequenos buracos
ou poros no filtro no tecido então esses
poros se tornam maiores e mais espaçados
do que o normal o pó de café e as
partículas maiores vão começar a se
misturar com líquido passando para
xícara no caso do intestino hiper
permeável é como se o filtro intestinal
estivesse deixando passar substâncias
indesejadas para corrente sanguínea
então quando a barreira intestinal está
comprometida permitindo que essa substân
nocivas vazem pra corrente sanguínea
nosso sistema de defesa imune ativado
então isso pode resultar em uma reação
em cadeia levando a inflamações crônicas
e uma série de sintomas e
doenças exemplo doença de rimoto agora
vamos falar sobre algo extremamente
importante como podemos identificar se
estamos lidando ou não com o intestino
hiper permeável primeiro é importante
entender que muitas condições de saúde
especialmente doenças autoimunes como
doenças inflamatórias intestinais a
doença de crom a acolito Cativa a doença
celíaca Artrite reumatoide lupus
tiroidite rimoto e muitas outras estão
intimamente ligadas à saúde do nosso
intestino então se você está enfrentando
alguma dessas doenças dessas condições é
bastante provável que tenha algum grau
de permeabilidade intestinal aumentada
Mas e se você não tem uma doença
autoimune diagnosticada Quais são os
sinais que podem indicar o intestino
hiper permeável os sintomas intestinais
são os mais óbvios sind intestino
irritável
alterações no ritmo intestinal com
episódios de diarreia ou constipação mas
existem sinais mais claros primeiro
sinal é um aumento das reações
alimentares Sabe aquela pizza que era o
ponto alto do seu sábado à noite ou a
sua salada favorita que sempre caía bem
pois é agora el elas parecem não te
entender mais você come e logo sente o
abdômen inchado surgem os gases ou
aquela sensação desconfortável que não
era comum antes parece que do nada o seu
corpo decidiu mudar as regras do jogo
com certos alimentos e o mais intrigante
você também pode ter reações alimentares
imprevisíveis Às vezes você come algo e
se sente bem mas em outra ocasião o
mesmo alimento provoca desconforto
segundo sinal é um enchaço abdominal
imprevisível ou que progride ao longo do
dia imagine começar o dia se sentindo
leve com abdômen plano mas conforme o
dia passe você se alimenta parece que
você foi se enchendo até se sentir como
se tivesse engolido um balão de festa
Esse aumento progressivo do inchaço
transformando o seu abdômen em uma
verdadeira bola de festa até o final do
dia aponta por uma condição chamado cibo
essa sigla que significa excesso de
crescimento bacteriano no intestino
delgado esse excesso ocorre quando tem
um fenômeno de super crescimento
bacteriano no intestino delgado
basicamente quando bactérias que
deveriam estar no intestino grosso
decidem fazer uma viagem Não autorizada
pro Delgado Esse é um sinal clássico de
cibo que está diretamente ligado à
hiperpermeabilidade
intestinal já o terceiro sinal é dor por
todo o corpo pessoal Imagine que se de
repente seu corpo começa a agir como
alarme disparando dores nas articulações
dores de cabeça uma sensação de que seus
músculos estão doloridos por toda parte
tudo isso um dia ou dois depois de uma
refeição específica parece um mistério
mas na verdade pode ser o seu corpo
sinalizando que algo não está bem com a
forma como ele está reagindo aos
alimentos Então essa conexão entre o que
comemos e como o nosso corpo responde em
relação às dores pode ser um sinal Claro
de alerta para hiperpermeabilidade
intestinal o quarto sinal que devemos
considerar são as infecções intestinais
frequentes se você notar que tem um
estômago fraco entre aspas que
frequentemente sofre com desarranjos
diarreia após comer fora de casa ou que
está mais suscetível a viroses
alimentares em comparação com as pessoas
ao seu redor isso também pode ser um
sinal seu intestino pode estar mais
vulnerável a infecções devido uma
hiperpermeabilidade uma permeabilidade
intestinal aumentada o quinto sinal é um
aspecto também importante que é questão
de ácio estomacal ter um baixo teoro de
áo no estômago chamada hipocloridria que
pode se manifestar através de sintomas
como dor de estômago frequente gastrite
refluxo ou até mesmo úlcera estomacal
pode ser um indício de
hiperpermeabilidade intestinal Além
disso se você frequentemente enfrenta
deficiências nutricionais apesar de uma
dieta equilibrada isso pode ser uma
bandeira vermelha dificuldade de manter
os níveis de Ferro vitamina B12 sempre
baixa ou a necessidade constante de
suplementar vitaminas são indícios de
que seu intestino Pode não estar
absorvendo nutrientes de maneira eficaz
outra consequência possível da Hiper
premil intestinal sexto sinal são as
alterações de pele pense na sua pele
como espelho que reflete o que acontece
no seu interior quando você enfrenta
problemas persistentes de pele como
eczema acne coceira vermelhidão rosá
dermatite atópica psor
é como se esse espelho estivesse
transmitindo um sinal de alerta no seu
intestino assim como problemas na
Fundação de uma casa podem causar
rachaduras nas paredes problemas do
intestino podem se manifestar através da
sua pele e esse é um sinal importante
para nós médicos já o sétimo sinal é uma
fadiga persistente Imagine sua energia
como uma bateria de celular mesmo depois
de uma no de carga se você acorda
sentindo que está com 10% de bateria
apenas como um cansaço que atrapalha
suas atividades
diárias lutando para se concentrar
durante o trabalho Vivendo em um
nevoeiro mental pode ser um sinal de que
seu intestino está drenando a sua
energia por conta das alterações
causadas pela hiperpermeabilidade
intestinal problemas
hormonais que afetam tanto homens quanto
mulheres podem ser especialmente
difíceis de controlar quando o intestino
está comprometido por exemplo se você
luta com o ajuste da ação para o
hipotiroidismo ou se os seus anticorpos
relacionados ao Hashimoto estão sempre
elevados isso pode ser um reflexo de um
intestino hiper permeável e não podemos
esquecer condições como diabetes
obesidade crônica gordura no fígado ou
esteatose hepática e até doenças
neurodegenerativas como Alzheimer paxon
e autismo também podem ter as suas
raízes nesse problema intestinal Então
pessoal O que exatamente causa Esse
aumento na permeabilidade do intestino é
uma pergunta complexa porque não existe
uma única causa muitos fatores
contribuem para esse problema começando
pela dieta Porque vivemos numa era de
alimentos altamente processados e fast
food nossa alimentação diária repleta de
produtos que mais parece ter saído de um
laboratório do que da natureza são
pobres em fibras são ricos em açúcares
em xarope de milho de alta frutose então
também são ricos em conservantes
corantes aditivos espessantes todos
esses elementos não naturais acabam
danificando a barreira intestinal
favorecendo o desenvolvimento do
intestino hiper permeável Outro ponto
importante é o famoso glúten pessoal
estudos apontam que independentemente de
se você ter ou não doença celíaca
sensibilidade ao glúten ou até nenhum
problema aparente com essa proteína o
glúten Pode sim prejudicar a integridade
da barreira intestinal também certos
adoçantes especialmente os artificiais
os antibióticos e os medicamentos
antiinflamatórios assim como os
inibidores de bomba de próton os famosos
prazois também entram na lista de
substâncias que podem comprometer e
muito a nossa saúde intestinal e não
podemos esquecer das toxinas ambientais
desde os compostos petroquímicos como os
poluentes da indústria do plástico os
pesticidas ou agrotóxicos como é o caso
do glifosato e até os metais pesados
outra coisa que pode contribuir são as
toxinas do mofo que podem povoar nosso
intestino e danificar Nossa barreira
intestinal um dado interessante que as
deficiências e vitaminas também podem
contribuir para enfraquecer a nossa
barreira intestinal especialmente a
vitamina A a vitamina D ou hormônio D
existem estudos associando a falta
dessas vitaminas A hiperpermeabilidade
ou permeabilidade intestinal
aumentada pessoal depois de tudo isso
que eu falei é claro que o desafio é
grande é bem desafiador mas é possível
melhorar e curar o nosso intestino por
isso estou pensando em preparar um
conteúdo especial focado em Como podemos
cuidar tratar e até curar o intestino
hiper permeável se você tem interesse
nesse tema por favor deixe nos
comentários aqui embaixo eu quero saber
a sua opinião e contar com seu apoio
para desenvolver um material que faça
diferença não esqueça de curtir o vídeo
e compartilhar com quem precisa dessa
informação espalhe o conhecimento de
qualidade espalhe o link desse vídeo no
seu WhatsApp e outras redes sociais a
sua participação é muito importante para
poder continuarmos abordando temas tão
importantes paraa nossa saúde muito
obrigado pela sua atenção um grande
abraço um beijo no seu coração Você é
fera